[Musique]
alors ce week-end nous organisons des
randos solidaire de l'institut ici sur
le site du château de la verrière donc
il fait partie du domaine de l'institut
mgen
ces randonnées sont à la fois des
randonnées pédestres et des randonnées
cyclistes de cyclotourisme au total six
parcours 3 pédestre et trois cycles au
[Musique]
lit à interdire cet établissement
une association et des soignants qui
mène des projets d'innovation
thérapeutique
les recettes de participations serviront
aussi à financer les projets en question
[Musique]
les horaires d'inscription pour ce qui
concerne les parcours de cyclotouristes
c'est à partir de 7h30 le matin jusqu'à
9 heures et pour les parcours pédestres
et de 8h30 à 9h30 on est à fixer c'est
ces tranches horaires en fonction aussi
des durées de parcours de façon à ce que
tout le monde revienne à fourmies dit
sachant qu'à 11h30 il y aura un buffet
et une collation pour le pôle et pour
les comprends pas les concurrents mais
les partis en randonnée les cartes deux
parcours sont disponibles sur internet
on peut les télécharger en format pdf ou
en format gpx pour ceux qui ont des gps
[Musique]